den urknall so nah wie noch nie mit dem
sogenannten gravitationslinsen effekt
konnte erneut eine große anzahl an
galaxien entdeckt werden die bisher im
verborgenen lagen und den forschern
etwas ganz besonderes ermöglichen
herzlich willkommen beim blick vom
ganzen fiktiv um sternen an sammlungen
wie die die jetzt von forschern der
university of texas in austin entdeckt
wurden überhaupt registrieren zu können
gehört etwas glück die strahlung der
galaxien ist nämlich eigentlich durch
schwach dass man sie kaum
beziehungsweise nur ganz schlecht
aufzeichnen kann dabei hat aber wieder
mal der physikalische effekt namens
gravitationslinse geholfen galaxien und
vor allem galaxienhaufen haben eine so
starke gravitation dass sie zeit und
raum um sich herum krümmte und menschen
auf der erde ist dieser effekt manchmal
super hilfreich wenn die linse die durch
die gravitation entsteht wirkt auf lupe
objekte die sich hinter dieser lupe
finden werden extrem stark vergrößert
hinter der lupe dass galaxien clusters
apple 74 fanden wir 94 und hinter der
linse des class of next 04 16 befanden
sich 73 der sogenannten ersten galaxien
warum aber strahlen diese so schwach und
was macht sie deswegen überhaupt so
interessant und besonders der name erste
galaxien schon verrät handelt es sich
hierbei um galaxien aus der frühzeit
unseres universums
die insgesamt 167 galaxien müssten kurz
nach dem urknall entstanden seit nicht
mal 700 millionen jahre nach dem großen
knall hätten sich einige dieser uhr
galaxien gebildet diese vorher
entstehungszeit stellt einen ganz neuen
rekord auf die letzten gefundene nur
galaxien wurden auf ein alter von rund
13 milliarden jahren geschätzt den
wissenschaftlern ist es also ort
wörtlich gelungen noch ein ganzes stück
weiter in die vergangenheit zu schauen
also so weit in die vergangenheit wiegt
die fährt noch niemand den 13 milliarden
jahre alte galaxien sie deutlich später
als 700 millionen jahre nach dem urknall
entstanden warum weshalb die wann wo und
was eigentlich überhaupt die wenigsten
fragen rund um den urknall konnten
bisher geklärt werden mit einem blick
wie dem der jetzt erneut gelungen ist
könnte man den antworten auf die vielen
fragen näher kommen
viel programm im zuge dessen diese
entdeckung gelungen ist läuft allerdings
nur noch bis 2018 in münchen wird aber
an einer anderen technologie gearbeitet
die bei der forschung rund um den
urknall helfen soll
mehr dazu hier und drückt mir ein auf
auge wenn er den kanal abonnieren
wollten nächste verpassen geht mir gerne
noch einen auch die glocke dann kriegt
er über eine nachricht wenn sie neues
video gibt ansonsten gesamtplatz